and I look forward to Killing Joke oh
yeah I know about that I'm telling you
be careful what you wish for because I
kept saying you know when when Joker was
over for me I said you know what we
ought to do is we are you killing Joe
and the thing is it's not for kids
and I really apologize it's rated R
oh thanks Chelsea but it's really mean
and nasty and by the way for you Alan
more fundamentalists of which I am one
it's not because I thought of it as a
book on tape where we can do every
single word right and just do music and
sound effects because Alan Moore doesn't
like anything that they do you know be
for Vendetta he didn't like they didn't
like Watchmen it's just you know he's
perfectionist so he's going to hate
killing Joe but it's killing children's
embedded in a larger story that I can
tell you involves that girl and Batman
and I like I say it's it's earned it's
our rating I mean they they really did
it like the book and I can only tell
kids kids will come up to me and say oh
I'm so excited for The Killing Joke I
said you watch that
because it got progressively weirder and
Archers we got into the videogames
here's a quote from from Killing Joke
memories so treacherous one moment you
lost in a carnival of delights with the
poignant childhood aromas flashing neon
puberty all that sentimental candy floss
next it leads you somewhere you don't
want to go somewhere dark and cold and
filled with the damp and big.you a
shapes of things you'd hope with
forgotten memories can be filed
repulsive little ruse like children I
suppose
thank you our having fun now